vacation hello everyone
yeah I will continue the session after
Richards the introduction of the
shakealert and my shake
so I'm Ching Kai I'm a graduate student
to working at Berkeley seismology lab so
I'm trained by I'm actually trying to as
a seismologist but also I'm interested
in the data science machine learning so
that's the way actually we try to adopt
a lot of the great algorithms to in data
science machine learning back to
seismology so this project actually is a
very nice test field for us to like
adopt these new methods and new
algorithms and this project my shake is
a joint effort between Berkeley
seismology lab and also t-mobile to each
telecom Silicon Valley Innovation Center
so it's a collaboration between the
stree and also academia and also last
year more Foundation started to found us
as well as Richard mentioned that these
projects is still in the research modes
we are not ready to issue as quickly
warning yet but we are working really
hard to issue earthquake warning just a
little bit of recap of what Richard just
mentioned the goal is that we beautify
small size seismic night work using the
smartphone's in your pocket the sensors
in your phone actually can be used to
detect earthquakes so the ideal case is
that everyone download our my shake app
and turn your smartphone into a
seismometer and then you can see that
everyone actually working with their
walking with their smartphone sitting
there and if the earthquake occurred a
good portion of the smartphone's
detected the earthquake shaking and then
this information sent to the central
brain or the central server we can
actually aggregate the results from like
a large crowd off of phones and then we
can detect the earthquakes so this is
the goal of my shake in the real-time
real-time applications so we try to
detect the earthquakes as fast as we can
as long as we have the smartphone's
but the technology actually or the core
parts of my shake as Richard mentioned
is that everyone is like working with
your smartphone running maybe doing
other activities how we actually
recognize earthquakes from like the
other human activities so this is the
core part of my shake so today I will
try to make this as a tutorial like war
I try to show you the journey actually
we we address this problem what kind of
problems we we occur a way we actually
encountered and how we address them and
also what's the lessons we learnt and
hopefully this will be useful to you as
well even though maybe your application
is different in other domains but I
think a lot of the problems may share
the same characteristic like I mentioned
for our problem the number one challenge
is that everyone is moving with the
phones and we have people walking with
the phone runyan seeking they are
driving the car and so on and if we
record something you know like this on
your smartphone using the excel meter
how do we know whether this is a
earthquake or this is just some human
activities the order to answer this
question the first thing we need to do
is like we need to collecting data and
then we need to see how we're actually
dealing with this data to recognize
whether the movement is human activity
or the movement is earthquakes so this
is the first step we started this
project so you can see that we started
to collecting data so we built a
prototype system that we actually have
the app running on some testing from
and then we collect we starts to
collecting human activity data so this
is one human activity data in three
components since these phones if you if
you put the phone on the desk
it can measuring acceleration in three
dimensions two horizontal one vertical
and we started the the prototype system
actually here at Berkeley as Richard
mentioned that we need to choose one
platform to work with either Android or
iOS so we actually chose Android at that
moment because we think the Android they
have a lot of penetration around the
globe but when the funny thing is that
when we started to do the test here at
Berkeley and we found out that out of
was 300 students class only less than 10
people have the Android phones so but we
have to live with the situation and try
to try to recruit more volunteers of us
so altogether we actually recruit about
a 100 students and also friends and
families to help us to carry the phone
for six months to collecting the data so
although human activity data is looks
like this and then the other thing is
that we need to collecting the
earthquake data and then we try to see
what's the difference how we actually
recognize which ones earthquake which
ones not so this is a much harder
problem because earthquake not occur
very like a frequent in the last a few
years actually in barrier there's only a
couple for large earthquakes like the
Napa is quick a magnitude six in 2014
and also a lot of them are much smaller
earthquakes so we try to at that moment
we try to increase our earthquake data
recorded on the phone so we actually we
actually did the two things the first
thing is that we generated some things
insightiq data so this is the simulated
data we generated so how we did that is
that we have the traditional seismic
seismometers and then these are like
running for several decades record
there's a lot of recording
earthquakes on this type of sensors so
we first get these recordings from the
sensors traditional sensors and then we
dunk rates the quality of the sensor
that looks similar to the to the quality
that's recorded on the phone and also
the phone the phone sensor actually is a
much poor quality that have a lot of
noise so we actually grab the noise from
the phone recordings and we superimpose
on the on the earthquake data recorded
on the traditional sensors and use this
as a simulated data so you can see I'm
showing here is one earthquake example
from Southern California but you can see
the horizontal axis is the distance from
the epicenter and also the time is the
from zero that's the earthquake starting
time so the right Y is the raw data from
the sensor of the traditional
seismometer and the blue one is the one
we actually tank-raised and adding the
noise to simulate this is our earthquake
data so if you'll have a look very close
to the center it's a it seems like they
matching quite well but we you go
further and further away you're starting
to see this right red traces actually is
buried into the smartphone noise because
the smartphone noise is so high that a
lot of the times you can't see the
signals where well especially at further
distances so these sensors are really
good to detecting large motion but not
the smaller motion which can be detected
on the traditional sensors so this is
our initial starts we think that we
actually can only detect a larger
earthquakes during the if we release the
app to the to the smartphone sensors but
also in the in addition to this
simulated data set we also did a shake
table test the shake table test is that
we have a table probably like one sirs
the size of the one third of this room
like you can see basis
the shake table like fenced by this blue
blue plume here and this is some human
for scale so this table actually can
simulate earthquakes in three dimensions
and then we put all our smart phones
which actually is here and on the table
and then during the shaking of the table
these smart phones will pick up the
shaking movement and record it down the
acceleration and also by the way this is
the shaking test they are they are doing
at that moment so this is a column from
a bridge they try to see what kind of
shaking actually will will make will
make cracks or what's the response of
this column on the bridge response to
the earthquakes but if you zoom into
this this small small area where our
phones are so you can see our smart
phones we put on the test are on the
shaking table and in various
orientations and also we try to see
what's the effect see if we don't
coupling the the phone like the
traditional seismometers you early you
dig a hole in the ground and also your
ports you post the the sensor on the
like a concrete appear but a lot of the
times and know now if the users will let
you do that so that's why we need to
test if we just put the phone on the
desk what kind of signals actually we
can record to give you a sense how this
works so this is a movie actually
showing the shake table in action and
you can see now it's moving so this
table actually is simulates a large
earthquake and also due to the safety
issue we actually proposed that some
students carry the phone standing on the
table but they actually not allow us to
standing there just in case that some
students get injured and so on well this
is the way actually we got more
realistic earthquake data set so this is
another way we actually generates our
data set for the earthquakes and then
give you a sense what look it looks like
you can see this is the shake table data
recorded on the smartphone and recorded
on a reference sensor on the shake shake
table so you can see the black one are
recorded on one phone and the red one is
actually recorded on the on the same
sensor installed on the shake table so
you can see if I plot over each other
basically this is the raw waveform this
is the time of the shaking this is the
amplitude the the larger the wiggle is
and means that the larger the shaking is
and also you can see this is the future
data with just the future the data into
the frequency bands we are interested
you can see it's actually matching quite
well and we think at that moment is that
okay this data prove that these phones
actually can be used to detect the
earthquakes even though it's not put it
on the ground just to put on the Freddy
on the desk so this is the way either
either we prove our concepts but also we
collecting more data so this is actually
the ways we we collect in all the data
we have for the earthquake and non
earthquakes actually during the course
of collecting this data we we also
collected some real earthquake data
which is very similar to this during
during the six months and also another
thing to mention is that these sensors
if you think the traditional sensors
Richard just mentioned to detect the
earthquakes it can detect the
earthquakes very small earthquakes like
even the magnitude is like a point one
or point two but for the sensors of
these smartphones at about 10 kilometers
you can only detect about a magnitude
four or five depending on what type of
phone you are using high-end phones you
already have better sensors but the
low-end phones you have the low quality
sensors that you actually missed a lot
of the the even a large earthquakes so
this is the the inconsistent hardware
in the phones is another considering
issue for us to consider at that moment
but this is the data basically we
collected earthquake data and non
earthquake data so we we collected a lot
of these type of data and then we need
to think a way we actually can
distinguish earthquakes from now
earthquakes so actually starts to use
machine learning basically this is just
the overview I know a lot of people here
probably already have an idea of what's
machine learning but basically we have
the data we put the data into a tunable
model we use like optimization algorithm
to to basically to tune the model
parameters to get the results we want
and then after the trend model after we
trained the model with some of our
training data some magic things can
happen when we release the app in the in
the in the in the public into the public
so this is the basic idea of at the
moment after reflecting all this data so
for my sake actually the procedure is
very simple so we found out that if you
run in a classifier to continuously
classify whether the motion is
earthquake or not it's actually not
efficient with a very simple study
algorithm you can check whether the
phone is get steady or not for a very
short amount of time you filters out a
lot of the human activities already so
we actually in our workflow we have a
study algorithm basically checking
whether the phone is steady or not and
then we have a pre-filter to filter the
data into the frequency range if we are
interested and then if someone pick up
the form or someone moved to the desk
and this phone will trigger
algorithm we call sta RT a it's like a
short-term average over the long-term
average think about that and so the if I
have a signal running through time and
then if I use like two averages two as
an indicator
of whether there's a movement the short
term using a very short window it will
be very sensitive to something like a
sudden motion but if I have a long term
window if I take the average the
background noise I actually will average
out thus the spiky signals so this is
actually a very sensitive motion
detector to see whether my phone is
moved or not so but we won't talk more
about all these straight steps today I
want to talk more about the artificial
neural network once the phone moved by
someone how we recognize whether this is
earthquake or not so this is the focus
part of this presentation so basically
we use the artificial neural network to
recognize which one which motion is
earthquake which motion is not so yeah
just as some crash course on the
artificial neural network I think I
don't know like the audience probably
like most of them you know some sort
some level of like an artificial neural
network but I always think in a simple
high-level picture of artificial neural
network that when we were kids we try to
recognize which ones the Apple which
ones are orange so your parents give you
these two objects and then you started
to sensing the words like a color
texture shape taste and then these your
lis caught features and you memorize
these features into a mind and next time
when they give you an object for example
Apple and then you started you started
to compare the features in your mind and
then to see whether it's more likely as
a Apple or more likely as a orange but
sometimes you make mistakes for example
someone gives you an orange or like
someone gives you an apple but it's a
green color
maybe you never see that before you make
you make a wrong detection or you make a
wrong classification you say this is
maybe orange but then your parents you
know supervise the way tells you that
this is actually Apple then you update
the features that's actually saved into
a mind and then you actually use this
you
the future too kind you to make the
decision whether this is earthquake or
the weather this is Apple or this is
orange so this is a very high-level way
of artificial neural network so
basically it's like it's a feedback loop
if you think that I have the input of
these features for example we described
in the previous example and we have some
processing components here to process
these features and then we have the
output whether it's an apple or orange
and then we we can measuring whether we
make the wrong decision or make the
correct decision and then we can tell
stage DC that we can tell this is like a
cracked needs of our the estimation well
back to the input layer basically saying
that if we make that we will make some
arrows next time we try to eliminate the
errors so this is the artificial neural
network in simple in simple way and I
try to give you an example hopefully
this is more clear I always like to use
this example I know I hope everyone
knows this is President Obama and also
dr. chaton Cooper in the Big Bang Theory
and so basically if we have a group of
pictures we try to classify which one is
Obama which one is a Sheldon Cooper and
we make the we basically try to train an
artificial neural network to do this how
we do that
so we basically put all our training
training pictures obama and a shot and
cooper and we extracted some features
for example the color of the skin eye
shape of the head nose and so on and
then we use these features to give that
into the artificial neural network and
these these connections between these
features to the artificial neural
network basically these are like the the
weights were the indicators which which
which features are more important which
features are not and then we can
generate the output for example if we
say
these pictures are Sheldon Cooper we
actually made a run detection and then
we actually can we since we know these
pictures are Obama you know supervised
the supervised the sense we basically
can calculate the arrow and then go put
in put this arrow back to the night work
and then updates the weights next time
for like adjusted the the learning parts
of the mouth nose and eyes which were
more important to for me to make the
correct decision
so basically this is the idea behind the
artificial neural network and then we we
actually next time we make the correct
detection will make the correct
estimation of digital albama
so exactly the same thing on the
earthquake signals if we have an
earthquake signal and non earthquake
signal we know which ones earthquake
which ones not and then we try to
extract the features from these time
series so we are actually using a two
seconds window within this two seconds
window we extract the features from the
two type of different movements why is
the earthquake why is a human activity
which can be used to characterize the
difference between the two types of
movement and then we use the sliding
window with one seconds overlap
basically you can think this this window
is moving every seconds we calculate
some features within this these two
seconds window and then use these
features to tell me which ones more
looks like an earthquake which one is
more looks like a non earthquakes so the
features we extracted actually at that
moment about like a three or four years
ago we we tested about sixty different
features more than fifty different
features so these features includes some
features from statistical sense like
statistical summary of the two seconds
window of the time series and some of
them are time domain signals like the
amplitude what's the shape looks like
what's the what
what's the the like the person tell of
the amplitude and so on and then some
frequency domain for example the FFT the
for real
faster Fourier transform and also the
wavelet transform and so on and also we
use the some of the features in
seismology so we try to we try to select
the features to give us a clearer sense
of what's the physical meaning behind so
that we know what type of movements have
these kind kind of features or patterns
that we can actually use that to
distinguish which ones earthquake which
one's not so we actually tested all
these 50 more than 50 features and then
with like with first we think that we
don't need a lot of we don't need all
these features and also we think that
implementing on the phone we don't want
to have a lot of features running on the
phone so that's why we actually select a
subset of them to be running on the
phone so that we can use that to detect
the earthquake and non earthquakes so we
use a feature selection schema so which
basically a process that you select the
most important features or subsets of
the features that running in these all
50 different features so it has the
different ones that we at last we
basically select the forward Grady
selection means that we starts with non
features and then every time when we do
to the iteration we're adding one new
features into into our training and then
we monitoring what's the improvement
basically every time after I add a new
variable or new feature into it and we
select the feature that gave us the
maximum improvement on the model so
using this way actually we selected the
best of three features you can see when
we use one or two features the the
dishes like the trinium performance
going up is going higher higher
performance and this is like a number of
features we are using with more and more
features
we can see at the the beginning we are
actually increasing the performance of
the detection but then later due to like
an either overfitting or other issues
like the maybe the correlations between
different features we're starting to see
a slightly drop of the performance but
we selected the three features that we
think is the best of three features
gives us both gives us a nice
performance and at the same time gives
us a nice interpretation of what's the
meaning behind the different failure
different movements so we use these
three features actually to implement on
the smartphones to detect earthquakes so
these are the three features the zero
crossing so which is basically a simple
indicator to indicate that your
frequency change under under movement
for example if I change my my hand like
this so it will be relatively higher
higher zero crossing so you can see
every time my signal crosses the
baseline I count one so basically it's
an indicator of what's the dominant of
frequencies and also if I change I've
moved my my phone slowly it's relatively
lower number of this zero crossing and
also we use inter content
basically this gives us what's within
this two seconds window of detection
what's the average amplitude what's the
the shaking intensity with the most of
the shaking intensity within this two
seconds window so these features tells
us how fast you four moves this feature
tells you how large you four moves and
then this is a feature we use the in
seismology we call it the cumulative
absolute velocity which gives you the
average energy then within this two
seconds window tells you like what's
within this two seconds window how much
I actually moved and so on so these
three features actually
we found out that they actually tells us
a lot about different type of motions
earthquakes and non earthquakes and also
by the way there's some features
actually works better for example this
is just a simple indicator of the the
frequency domain signal what's the
dominant frequencies and we found out
that actually uses some of you use the
coefficients of the wavelet transform
actually we have a better performance
but it's also use much more resources on
the phone if you implement it on the
phone
so selecting these features is kind of
like a trade-off between the performance
and also how easy or resort how much
resources it's used on your phone so we
actually came up with these three
features running on the phone and we
found out that it can separate most of
the human activities from the
earthquakes so this is the the place
actually we started to implement that on
the phone I will stop here gesture to me
to see if there are any questions feel
free to interrupt and ask me more
questions if you if something is not
clear but anyway so after we selected
these three features which an artificial
neural network so basically we we found
out that we can train a very simple
artificial neural network standards like
input layer hidden layer and output
layer and then to calculate whether my
motion on the phone is from earthquake
or non earthquakes so this is the
architecture actually from our
implementation on the phone it's just
like of five neurons you know one hidden
layer with three features and then we
treat with this like trend model so I
actually have these figures here I think
it's very interesting to show one trend
is that like if you think that what you
are doing as a machine learning ID
engineer or data scientist a lot of
people think you are doing very calm
located things but these states actually
you you have a lot of food like the
packages that you don't need to spend a
lot of time to implement this algorithm
so you basically maybe check with just a
one line of the import you solved all
your problem so this is exactly what I
learned see is that I spent almost one
semester to basically implement the
artificial neural network from scratch
and then after that I after maybe Wow -
years later I found out that the IRS's
existing packages that you can actually
implement that again one afternoon so
which actually is taking the trend
basically saying that these days you can
do a lot of more efficient work with the
existing community but anyway at that
moment who I as a PhD student spends the
whole semester to implement the
artificial neural network one good thing
is that you actually have a better
understanding over the artificial neural
network but the otherwise that you lose
the half of you lose the one semester
basically learning all these things but
anyway I will tell you a lot more
details of the trinium because I think
some of the training parts actually is
very interesting because this problem
actually have a lot of a typical problem
if you think that it's a typical machine
learning type of project one thing is
that so yeah we know that a lot of
models you can fit the data where well
like if I have the blue dots and the red
dots here you can have a lot of food you
can have a lot of models which one is
good which one is not like the right
what the blue the the basically the
green curve here actually gives me 100%
I can separate the data but you can see
this purple line here also gives me like
a saturate the most majority of the data
but a lot of them are making mistakes
this black line seems gives me the best
results in terms of separating these so
this is basically under faking and just
the rights and over
data so during the training of the model
so we basically train saturates our
training data set into Tesla and the
Trini so with with the earthquake data
and knowledge quick data we collect it
so we know that a lot of them actually
are non earthquake data so we we
actually first separate the training and
tests and then training the model only
on the 80% of the training data and then
test the model on the 20% of the data
that we never present to the training
process so basically you can see I think
the a lot of people know this is like a
learning curve which is like you can
train your model as long as you torture
your data really well you continuously
decrease your error rate but if you test
it on a new data set you always see like
elbows curve of that which indicates
that this is the place you should stop
your training basically this is the time
you use this model as you are your
implementation of the real world real
world model on the phone so we use the
10-fold cross-validation so basically
this is the idea is that every time you
use you cut the data into different
chunks and used use one chunk as that
has the data the rest of that to as the
training data and then you basically use
these to test your performance and also
select what's the architecture of the
artificial neural network is and also
one interesting aspect is that these
data set is also a very skewed data set
it's very it's a highly imbalanced data
set for example we have a lot of human
activity data but we have only a small
portion of the earthquake data if Y for
this example if I try to classify earth
apple and orange if I have nine thousand
data points all from the Apple only one
thousand data from the orange if I make
a classification
algorithm to estimate all our data is
Apple actually achieved 90% so this is
the effect of imbalance the data so this
is actually a huge problem also for our
data set because the earthquake data is
very limited so it's a several orders of
difference between earthquake data and
non earthquake data so we tried
different ones to address the imbalance
data we try to collect in more
earthquake data but it's very hard to do
the shake table test and also to record
the real earthquake data and also we
tried the resample our data set we over
sample the earthquake data set like if
we only have 1000 earthquake data we try
to sample we over some point to 10,000
data all way down sample the human
activity data to like from 10,000 to
1000 and also we try to generate more
synthetic data and also we tried the
different algorithms which insensitive
to the imbalance the data for example
the tree based data tree tree based the
decision tree based like algorithms or
models with penalize the model which we
penalize more if you make a drawing
decisions on the earthquake data or we
also tried like another perspective
instead of classification we also tried
the anomaly detection so in the last we
actually selected the best performance
which is weight on sample the data from
the human activity data and during our
test with this the the human eye the
volunteers the students are here we
found that actually works pretty well so
to give you a sense this is the training
data we have so this is the zero
crossing which basically coil here going
this way is more higher frequency and
this is the amplitude of the shaking
each dot C is 1 1 2 seconds window so we
actually have several million of human
activity data here in the over the
overlap with each other so you
see this is the human activity data but
if we're plotting the earthquake data
from the shake table test and also from
the simulated data we can already see
the actually separates the most parts of
the data actually separated from each
other so we actually can trim a model
basically if which or decision boundary
across this data set we can separate
most of them but not all of them and
also in terms of town sampling the data
we tried to actually for the human data
like I mentioned it's a it's a highly
imbalance the data set we try to
randomly sample the human activity data
but we found out it's actually works
really poor because a lot of the human
data actually is within here like maybe
90% of the human data is within here
this is because a lot of the time the
human data is seeking on a desk have
very low noise low amplitude and a
broader of frequency content so this
data is people walking running with
relatively larger amplitude but
relatively smaller or like a low
frequency movement so if we just
randomly sample the data we actually
found out a lot of the data force here
so that's why we use another different
way to sample the data we actually use a
clustering algorithm the k-means
clustering algorithm to cluster these
human data into the centroids of the
each of the cluster group use that as a
representative of the human activity
data you can see with this this
clustering algorithm actually we get
more of the sampling of the much less
data from from the human activity
movements so with these sampling you can
see we actually reduce the several
milling human activity data to about
like the same number of the earthquake
data we use so this is the final data
showing you
where is the location where is the
feature location on these two feature
map so you can see this is the final
earthquake data you can still see
there's a lot of these ones over
basically are like overlap with each
other so this is the way if you just a
draw a decision boundary here you're
still making mistakes when they are over
overlapping with each other
so but anyway this is the final
classification schema we are using
basically we use three features for easy
visualization and plotting two features
why is the amplitude why is the
frequency and the earthquake data is the
red and non earthquake data is blue and
use this to classify which one is the
earthquake which one's not and if you
look at the third dimension the
cumulative absolutes of velocity we
found that a lot of the overlap data
points actually got stretched into the
third dimension that actually when you
do when you train the model to build the
decision boundary it helps you to make
the decision better to for a lot of
these overlapped data so this is the
three features we feel that reasonably
good to implement on the phone and at
the same time it's also reasonably easy
to calculate not use a lot of resources
on the phone to join the battery to use
two competing other apps to use the
resources so the earthquake data is
generated from this shake table test yes
and also the simulation data and so by
generating you know signatures with
certain statistics you can basically
achieve whatever success rate in the
classification you like right yes that's
right so how do you how do you decide
how many red points essentially to put
there oh yes so you in the very nice you
know a very simple way the more data you
have the better because it captures of
different variabilities of the
earthquakes we try to act
three grab all the data we can find like
all the global earthquake data we can
find that recorded on the traditional
seismic Network and also we try to keep
a parent say Oh for like him I'm doing
the whole year of shaking table test at
Richmond field station here
so basically try to grab as much as data
we can have to trim the artificial
neural network yeah but the other thing
is that for the human activity data we
collected the for the whole six months
using that as the training data did I
answer your question yes sir the 93
percent what exactly does it correspond
to so I'm going to tell you more a
little bit more so the 93 it's
corresponding to five noises of the
human data which is like all the
earthquake data we are actually worked
out to train the model and then we use
that to we we also have like a twenty
percent of the test data so this is
basically the test of arrow I'm
reporting here so basically this is same
ninety percent of the time human human
triggers are correctly classified as
like a human triggers but seven percent
of the time it's wrongly detected as
earthquakes yeah but also let's let's
bring up these performance evaluation so
just to quickly refresh because
sometimes I feel this is a confusing tap
one arrow and the tab to arrow
you can see for the type one error it's
very simple that if you don't have
earthquakes but you make earthquake you
make the decision this is earthquakes
but for the type 2 error which you have
earthquakes but you actually completely
missed it so these two types of arrow is
the one we actually can make during our
implementation of the artificial neural
network so this is a quick evaluation so
all this data is not in present in the
training but you can see four different
earthquakes within so the actually the
type
arrow is different depending on the
distances because close to the distances
you have more energy from the earthquake
you are more likely to detect it you can
see this is to number the second number
showing you how many smartphones within
these with within within 10 kilometers
of this earthquake and then this is the
number actually how many phones actually
detected the earthquake you can see
within 10 kilometers only one phone
didn't detected these Parkview magnitude
6 earthquake but then when you go to 30
kilometers for this earthquake you
actually have more phones didn't detect
the earthquake and also for smaller
magnitude earthquake because the energy
release is much smaller you actually see
going further and further away you have
less detection rate so this is but we
think that within 10 kilometres for the
large earthquakes larger than magnitude
5 most of the earthquake signal can be
detected by our trained artificial
neural network and also for the human
activities so you can see that we use 1
month data actually as our training they
test the data set so we actually have
like a 7% about 7% of them are detected
as earthquakes these are more causing
problems like when they when they detect
there's earthquakes you may assume the
wrong earthquake alerts but remember
this is just on one phone so but think
about 24 hours if I my phone reporting
7% of 24 hours as earthquakes it's
actually still a lot of times so that's
why not only we need to have this
earthquake detection algorithm running
on the phone but also we need a way to
aggregate the results from multiple
phones because it's simple to have one
phone detecting it's an earthquake and
you don't know whether it's earthquake
or not but it's not easy if a whole
bunch of phones within one region
actually triggered as earthquakes for
example within 10 kilometers all my
phone seat thinks it's a
earthquake so the probability of it's a
randomly triggered by human activity
actually is really low so this is
actually the idea of the second level of
the detection algorithm on top of the
artificial neural network running on
your phone and then that's actually stay
that's basically running on the server
to aggregate the results from multiple
smartphones so this is just a simple
cartoon showing you if you in one region
I have these smart phones this is all
the active smartphones running my shake
and then our detection algorithm the
second level actually we tried different
the clustering algorithm and also
basically you can think if I want to
aggregate results from multiple phones
so it's a clustering post in time and
space so we think that we actually if
you sum in one region for example in per
area other phones starting to report
earthquakes the probability of a force
alert is really low for example I have
four phones starting to think I'm
experiencing an earthquake and then we
can say which all a circle of these four
phones like the fourth furthers the
distance between the the the like the
centroids of these four phones and then
we can actually ask the question how
many phones within this circle and
what's the percentage of these phones
starting to detecting earthquakes so
currently our threshold is starting at a
60% within these ten kilometers ray
radius and if we sixty percent of the
phones are detecting an earthquake we
think this is likely an earthquake so
this is where Richards shown you before
like this is the starting of the
earthquake and then you can see a bunch
of phones is starting to detect the
earthquake it becomes red and then
weights actually above sixty percent
within the red region starting to detect
earthquakes we actually detected this
earthquake which is shown as these
like a green star here and then we can
say this is a real earthquake and then
this is actually the way we we
clustering them based based agin space
and also in in time and we actually run
these on our data sets we found within
the last two years actually it works
reasonably well for the for a lot of the
regions and that we didn't generate any
of the force alerts because this sixty
percent rule it's very hard to to
actually exceed this rule because within
your region all the phones are starting
to shaking due to some other effect is
very low so we actually also try to use
the students on campus to ask all the
students carry my shaky phone and go to
a football game and then see whether
they wouldn't they all maybe there's a
score or something whether they can
trigger the the system or not so
actually that's not trigger a tie at all
so but we think this algorithm actually
works reasonably good for our first
first detection of the our girls but
anyway there's another issue needed to
consider in the real-time detection is
that I detected the earthquake but then
you have more information
starting from other phones but these
phones you need to try to associate
these phones with this event you already
detected because if you don't associate
them correctly they will say I have
experienced an earthquake here I
detected another earthquake here I
detected another earthquake so your
system will start to like you system
will starts to like a report earthquakes
all over the world so that's why you
need try to associate these triggers for
the event the way we trick we associated
it actually we try to take the physics
into the consideration or the problem so
you can see this is the distance from
the App Center and this is the dist this
is the time from the earthquake
so the seismic wave actually
suppose at a certain speed so this green
one curve showing you what they expected
a seismic wave travels for the P wave
which is the faster traveling wave and
which is the the red why is the slowing
movement order the ice wave so you can
see they actually have a pattern here
that if you have any thoughts before the
P wave it's likely not an earthquake
trigger and if you have a thoughts like
a far away from this line here it's
actually also not earthquake so we
actually incorporate these physics like
the how fast the P and S wave can travel
take into our problem and implement into
our system and it rejects the triggers
if I have a trigger far away from the
the ice wave arrival time it's it's
likely it's not a earthquake detection
and also if I have triggers before the P
wave is also probably either the clock
is wrong or it's triggered by something
else so this actually taking the physics
into our model actually helps us a lot
to associate the triggers for the more
and more phones triggered by the
earthquakes so this is like the way we
implement it on our phone and then we
actually spend a lot of time to verify
whether the algorithm is work and then
we realize that the otherwise is I think
Richter didn't mention is that when you
build these large-scale projects like
these whole systems and it works well
very well and then when you release to
the public and then you have all sorts
of queries so we actually spend last a
year a lot of times we are actually
addressing the technical issue on the
implementation side so for example we
released the a pagina Friday afternoon
you know Friday afternoon and we soon
learned the lesson that you shouldn't
release the app in the Friday afternoon
and then you will see that all your
engineers is disappear for the weekends
and then if you have any problems then
you will actually in trouble so our
system released and we all have a pet
how many people will download our app
our our crazy ki Cassie is like about
like a 10,000 phones actually within the
first few days we actually gotten like
eighty thousand phones like a download
our apps so which actually crashed our
server crashed our implementation
several times but anyway this is just as
some lessons we learned during the
course of implementation they implement
this and also you've got all the kinds
of who require request war requirements
from the users as well but anyway we as
Richard shows that we right now we
almost have about 300,000 people
downloads the app all over the world and
help us to detect the earthquakes so for
the real-time detection algorithm like
Richard mentioned that we actually a lot
of the times we didn't detect it because
we don't have the enough density because
a lot of these phones have low quality
that you need a really large earthquake
and the really large density within the
App Center that you can tell you can
actually detect it but if you run
offline so this is basically this about
eight hundred earthquakes we detected
from this smartphone data is of the fact
that we are already collecting the data
we already know there something happens
then we actually can see we will
recorded like about 800 earthquakes but
this is not in real-time the real-time
ones right now we only detected like a
four larger earthquakes of three in
California one in New Zealand and so on
so but anyway this is also brings
another issue is that like we have these
wrong decisions about like the
earthquake now earthquakes in real time
because we only use two seconds window
currently we are also explaining try to
understand or try to detect the
earthquakes using another approach on
the server
because if we want to detect them in
real-time we only have two seconds
information because we want to detect
them as fast as we can we can't use for
example 10 seconds war 1 minutes that
we'll use used up a lot of time for our
detection but on the server part after
the earthquake we actually collected a
lot of waveforms data five minutes data
and you can see this is an earthquake
data this is a human activity data but
if you see done at a longer time scale
you actually see very easy or relatively
easy to detect them so due to the time
constraint I won't go to the details
about the budget right now we are using
the convolutional neural network which
is methods really good at detecting the
images so basically we treat the image
you can think that we treat the images
as a real food pixel numbers and then we
actually try to yeah I won't go to the
details about the convolutional neural
network but we try to form the image of
earthquakes and non earthquakes from the
whole waveforms we collected we
collected on the backend server because
we have much longer time scale and then
you can see this image we formed using
the data from earthquakes and this image
actually we reformed using data from now
earthquakes so you can see a lot of
times even by eye you can see some sort
of pattern already from the earthquake
and non earthquake and then we trim the
earth we train actually the
convolutional neural network so this is
our model basically we form the image of
the earthquake from the wave form we
collect it and then we use the
convolutional neural network actually
really nice successful rate based on our
our tests but right now the problem is
still that we have so many of the human
activity data and the earthquake data is
still a very friction like even we have
about 800 earthquakes data
still compared with the humor activity
data which is in the order of millions
of data so it's still a small portion so
we are thinking ways like a transfer
learning to bring in other domain like
knowledge whether we actually learned a
lot of a similar effect for example in
music when they try to detect a certain
type of things maybe some features
actually can be used by our night work
and so on
but this is all the things we are
exploring and I think I will stop here
and if you have any questions or any
suggestions let me know I think the time
is running out so which is a perfect
okay any questions I knew I mean when
you have this positive trigger from a
phone you send these three statistics
which were which the trigger was based
on no we are actually not sending these
three statistic basis is all calculated
on the phone and the phone will based on
this research three features so it will
tell me whether this motion is more like
earthquake or not if it's more like an
earthquake then send a message which
contains the location of the phone the
time of the trigger and also what's the
amplitude of the shaking back to our
server and then the server will
aggregate this very short messages of
the location and the time things like
one of them is basically frequency or a
number of zero crossings yes between
different phones detecting
yes yeah we think it actually works well
is because the earthquake frequency
euerle the dominant the dominant shaking
actually is within certain frequency
range and during that dominant the
frequency range the amplitude also have
some pattern if you combining these two
information a lot of the human
activities you see that it's when you
walk with the phone when you pick up the
phone it's relatively low frequency
movement to compare with the earthquakes
and then but the amplitude actually is
larger than the earthquakes but if you
put the phone on the desk or a table so
the frequency can be like a relatively
broader but the amplitude is much
smaller compared with the earthquakes so
that's why we think it actually works in
our case to detect the earth most of the
earthquakes but also we found out a lot
of some sometimes when we do the test we
found out a lot of the transition
between different motion actually have
some similar similar features as the
earthquakes that's when the detection
algorithms starting to confusing and
make the wrong decision so yeah but then
that's taken care by the by the night
worker detection algorithm what so why
have you tried then what were you trying
what you get if you do take like the
actual frequency data from two different
phones and compare them because you'd
expect as long as two people or at least
say a hundred feet away from each other
that all of the noise should be almost
completely independent and so you'd
expect it to be very noticeable it's so
whereas any earthquake system would be
like highly correlated yeah rather than
just like sit because I guess the thing
you're just are creating basically one
bit from each person yeah actually we do
test that we we try to see in our two
years data how many people within one
area actually can trigger almost at the
same time during our running of my shake
even in Perea where
we have the tiniest smartphones at a
certain time within like 20 seconds
window for example I'm if I'm looking
looking at a 20 seconds window it's
rarely to have more than four phones
actually triggered at the same time
because a lot of these activities
especially the human activities few
turns out by the artificial neural
network but for the earthquakes within
20 seconds window you actually see a lot
of these triggers by the detection
algorithms so we're asking though is
like if you just look at the actual like
frequent the actual sensor data and
compare say the sensor data from two
different people without like but
without you know running this like local
neural network on X can you by comparing
those two can you get a better result
for am tracfone from for whether they're
for their respect is due to noise or due
to an earthquake than you would if you
just looked at the frequency data on one
sensor oh oh I see so basically you are
saying like a from like maybe phones at
a certain distances and I just to try to
correlating these human activities who
ours quakes data we happen to try that
but yeah that might be a way but we yeah
we haven't tried that you know we think
that the human activities a lot of the
times it unless the many people starting
to run at the same time at the same
location but a lot of this data
currently filtered out by our data like
the art of artificial neural network
approach but we can try that yes
features again operating on a single
phone that you're looking at are kind of
isotropic that they they don't they
don't distinguish between compressive
nature and share and sheer motion
for instance is that is that the case
and is there something to be gained from
Kent can these detectors since well you
you have there's a compass you have some
kind of maybe notion of Orient of
reliable more or less orientation could
be gained from looking at the
anisotropic aspects of the motion yeah
right now we are not yeah I know that's
probably better
that's right so for a lot of these
currently the the sensors on the phone
is it it's highly depending on like
what's the sensor quality is so for the
very nice sensors actually you you do
see the p-wave and s-wave for some
earthquakes and you can tell the
difference between the like the
compressional wave and the shear wave on
the on these sensors but a lot of the
phones yeah based on the like the
acceleration yes that's right but a lot
of these phones especially the low-end
phones you during the shaking for some
type of earthquakes you only see the
largest shaking which is the shear wave
shaking on these phones most of the like
the relatively modern rates magnitude
earthquakes you only see the largest
apportion on that but you can't see the
compressional waves on the on the phones
but we think for the larger earthquakes
especially in the magnitude six and
seven so the the compressional waves
actually triggers a lot of the function
we can actually take it advantage that
but for smaller earthquakes you need the
phone be very close to the App Center to
detect the the the P wave or the
compressional waves
so yeah that's depending either on the
sensor and on the location where you are
and I want some magnitude so things like
in your system you're able to tell which
phones are switched off may have the red
yes that's right no which ones are not
recording but are more honest
can you use the silence of a lot of
phones in something so the dog that
didn't bark right so you have you have a
bunch of points being triggered in a
certain area but a whole lot a bunch of
phones not being triggered does that
tell you I mean is it possible to use
that information - yeah that information
actually tells you about the magnitude
of the earthquake we are thinking so we
are actually thinking now because for
the larger is quick you actually see a
large area a lot of the phone she's
actually detected the earthquake but for
small earthquake you started to see a
lot of the phones didn't detect the
earthquake if you see the magnitude four
point four earthquake from Berkeley
event even though you can see we have 59
about 60 phones detected the earthquake
but a lot of them are didn't detect the
earthquake during this earthquake the
reason is that so when we train the
artificial neural network we kind of
will also know our lower lower
capability what type of earthquake we
can detect so our lower capability
actually is at about four point six so
it's it's it's actually at the border so
that's why you're starting to see a lot
of the the phones didn't trigger but
this actually tells you something about
the magnitude of the earthquake you can
use these information as an indicator of
large earthquake or smaller earthquakes
but also we we are thinking whether this
information also can tells you something
about like the detection as well but
right now yeah we just started that
process yeah in a major earthquake a lot
of the base stations are going to fail
you're going to get your alert out
before the base stations fail the base
stations fail enough seconds after the
initiation that's always debate whether
we use the high quality sensors or the
low quality sensors so the high quality
sensors definitely if we have the
efforts of time money and then we can
deploy them around the globe that would
be great it can detect a lot of these
earthquakes but at a lot of places we
actually do
question okay so you're depending on the
cell phone network okay sometime between
two seconds after the shaking starts and
thirty seconds after the shaking starts
the cell phone or base station the steps
open power you may enact okay right this
does nothing by itself it depends on
base station I see owned by my provided
by my cell phone carrier somewhere
around I would imagine to two to thirty
seconds into a major earthquake AT&T
space stations are going to shut down
t-mobile's base stations are gonna shut
down and so on yeah is this again this
this does your that affects both your a
build that affects your ability to meant
to met to measure and it event in it and
it affects your ability to successfully
to alert people right yes that's
actually a very good question yeah so no
it's actually nothing otherwise you will
hear the earthquake sounds an earthquake
but that's actually a really good
question for like the cell phone tower
weather during the earthquake whether it
will be disabled to war we know we know
history that are gonna be disabled so
but for the earthquake detection for the
smartphone's so if we actually have the
smart phones close to the epicenter so
it's way too early it's you can see the
example URI it's within like a like a
two hour five seconds then you starting
to have these phones to detect the
earthquake and then sending this out is
also like again in the order of like a
one or two seconds so but we think that
later maybe for later distribution of
the the users if the cell phone tower is
done so we probably will lose all the
connections but also I think there's a
project that they are monitoring these
type of cell phone towers and they can
also tell something about whether this
is our incoming like an ultra jawar
incoming earthquake and so on but yeah
we are not in
that type of study but we think that
these type of words quakes actually this
type of a system can activate at the
especially for the larger earthquake
these phones will starting to detect at
the P wave which is relatively small
motion so then we send out the message
and then even before the largest the
shaking starts so a lot of other places
already got the information yeah sort of
in detail in terms of the sort of the
daily rhythm of cell phone use your your
your blotting out when it's not steady
you have a steady yes basically bind and
switch on and off so so in that other
realm of operation I presume during the
daytime when when folks are in purses
and pockets around through that time
zone yes out of the cohorts that's true
do you have a feel for what kind of
fall-off do you get yes so we actually
based on our system in the last two
years during the day a lot of the times
we have about like a 10 to 15 percent of
the active phones actually it's
monitoring the earthquake but during
night so this percentage actually goes
up to 90 95 percent because a lot of the
phones are actually study but if you are
moving during the day so we think that
even 10 to 15 percent if we have enough
density so it's actually enough to help
you to detect earthquakes already so
yeah but it's true this night work not
like the traditional seismic night
worker you have a fixed configuration
this night working is basically always
changing during the time especially
during the day yeah so earthquakes occur
at night is the best time for us to
detecting the earthquakes
let's think again okay if you have more
questions